Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Emily is Away.
And now this is another game that got away from me
This is a free-to-play game available on Steam
and it was suggested a long time ago
*gasp*
I just didn't have the chance to play it  and it got forgotten
I'm sorry, but I'm here playing it now. So my screen name is
*Drawn out* Markiiimooooopeer... 69 *normal* Markimooper6, that's good enough
Mark
Bam!
My buddy icon is...
Is that Blink182? Hoo boy... Lord of the Rings? Harry Potter?
Oooh, the ring, I like that one, okay.
xjules, Bobby... ooh.
Hi!
Man, it's been so long since I used *laughs*
A-america instant mess - A.I.M.
Is that what it is even called, America Instant Messenger?
*gasp* Howdy!
That sounds like me! Howwd-ooh...
That's not what I...
*Making noises as he types*
Emily! Howdy
Oh that familiar sound *laughs*
Oh geez, before everyone had text messaging.
I like your new buddy icon, that movie is so scary!
What's up?
Uhhhh... *mumbles* the ceiling *to himself* Shut up.
Talking to you, super important! What are you up to?
Lol, well, no shit, I'm just listening to music.
Uhhh... do you like coldplay?
Ahhh... I'm not really a big fan of music in general...
*Hesitantly* I know one album of theirs... so...
*Sarcastically* Yeah, totally! Totally! Their last album was really good.
*mumbling* I don't know which one that was...
"Emily will remember that" Oh shit...
It really was! I'm so glad you like them, they're my favorite.
Their lyrics are in my info.. oh!
Can I...
Can I go to your info?
We live in a beautiful world, yeah we do, yeah we do... ooh...
I did not know that! Was that always there? Or was that just there now?
Let's see... are you going to Travis's party tonight?
Let's see... uhh... depends on if you're going.
Yeah.
Wait... Aww... what? No! I was- I- I could do the smiley face!
I could do that!
Lol, well I am, so you should go.
Let's see... It's crazy that we're already having end of school parties.
Wait, who was that?
Jules? *Mumbling as he reads the profile*
Brad Darko?
The dreams in which I'm dying are the best I've ever had.... man, why does everyone have musical lyrics?
Is that what people add in their profiles back then?
Not me... what do those numbers mean?
Is this important?
Lord... Lord minion 777... Wow! *laughs*
Lord minion 777 is here!
Huh... I like that! *laughs*
Lord minion 777... right there.
I can't wait for school to be over and
start my life as a youtuber butting same
here i'm so over this school year
does he like you know brad from our math
class he won't stop messaging me right
now are Brad darko what he's saying that
he wants to talk or something i'm not
really paying attention
oh man just one more month to graduation
we're so old i'm so excited for college
oh yes did you pick a school yet it's
gonna be so rad man I mean lady
yeah I didn't get accepted into my reach
school so I'm just going good one of the
others but that's ok anything's better
than high school
we're gonna go on engineering school
I'm not sure what kind of engineering I
want to do but I'm sure I'll figure it
out
that's pretty much a weird it story of
my life you chose to attend an
engineering school it's awesome you've
always been super smart i'm sure you do
really well that's so weird
even though we're going to different
schools do you promise you'll be there
for me
let's see oh absolutely nothing could
ever keep me from talking to you you're
my one you're one of my bedroll all
Emily will remember that you want mine
to you always will be mark oh wow it's
getting late i hope Julie gets here soon
so we can head to the party are you
leaving soon
ya soon as julie gets here then we're
both headed to traps party if you're
coming to you should probably leave soon
we'll see you there
definitely i'm so going to this red
party chose to attend the party but it's
so cool i'm going to go get ready
there's so many choices
oh that's cool see you soon see later
later cash keep it nice and cash in this
conversation later
oh I got an achievement said 2002
oh oh cool
Oh Hayley should pick of the matrix is
it still is it too early for that I do
like Nemo who I'm gonna go and the this
is when the later matrix movies where
I'm gonna go Nemo I'm full name him
again
oh Emily Emily hello
I like your new icon finding nemo's the
beast but hasn't shaken so k is shaking
i guess i'm just doing some homework and
listening to music to you know play
video games
I do all day every day 62 Coldplay huh
snow patrol they just came out with a
new album final straw have you heard of
it have I it's where something about car
chasing cars some something like that
you always know the best music oh geez
um let me just look up which one of
these is actually a snow patrol song
yeah that's one-run runs run
yeah oh yeah I really like yeah nailed
it nailed it
No so I like an engineering school or
and shit so boring i feel like i haven't
learned anything so far
you're too smart for your own good I'm
struggling with some classes from there
any plans tonight see Albert whoa God my
friend Mike throw a match about body
hell yeah hell yeah we're gonna have a
man raging Jagger don't get too drunk
no promises to drivers guess was this
personal profile my heart is bursting is
in your Perfect eyes as blue oceans .
skies
oh that's am release profile know
depends on how crazy the party gets do
you have plans tonight
nope brad has band practice on just
hanging out my room
wine you are no Brad Brad he's my
boyfriend you remember him from high
school
we've been dating for a couple months
now oh good i'm happy for you
yeah what yeah whatever other fried
plenty of Brad's at this house party i'm
going to i may go out with a few Brad's
I'm happy for you
how did you two get together anyway well
remember that grad party we went to last
year while I was away Brad send me a ton
of messages about how he felt at first I
thought it was really weird but after a
while I realized it was kind of brave we
started talking again over the summer
and realize we're going to the same
school once we got here which kinda hit
it off
what's he like is this the same Brad
that was really creepy really smart and
funny and he understands me
I'm smart and funny and understanding
sometimes you can be a jerk but when
it's good it's really good as he ever
mean to you getting into this is where
he can get pretty nasty when we argue
but that's it we're both very stubborn
people so we go back and forth a lot
like I said when things are good they're
really good
I don't want to be bold and claim that
it's a bad relationship guess its normal
man i feel like a young teenager because
I have a funny feeling that in this
circumstance the person that I'm
enacting is kinda having a crush on
little Everly over there so but saying
you deserve better isn't exactly
something nice to say when someone says
it's good it's good i guess yeah I guess
as normal as long as you're okay i am we
just get loud when we argue is all this
poor person o.o ah the good old teenage
years i'm gonna be bold here I wouldn't
treat you like that
what y no con
that's not what I said that's not what I
would have said all right
Emily will remember
for that oh jeez oh jeez
listen I think we're fine i don't want
to talk about anymore you should you
should break up with him
oh jeez what a type but I meant to say
what I come out a little better but I am
happy I promise
oh wow it's getting late you need to go
to that party don't you I can stay
no that's that's pitifully pathetic yeah
she doesn't want to talk about anymore
if there's were me i would i would go
and leave it where it was nothing you
can do about it you're in different
schools i mean what could you do it in
the term of this game and the person
what he wants
oh and what would I do what would I do
well this is about me this is about what
i would do and I'm I'd leave it where
was I mean I'd leave it where what she's
happy
I should be happy for so I should go
yeah I should go get around the
Riverbend ok later later later Gator
emily is a way oh is it away
ok 2004 sophomore are we gonna go
through the whole entirety of college
Oh incredibles incredibles you do 20 it
Emily up she's in a muse phase yo your
what all what up what up what word
not much as life I feel like we haven't
talked in awhile it's good it's good
yours plain lonely Lou that's fine got
any plans this weekend we're buddy
Wow go to Sochi car warehouse body with
my friend Emma
oh I didn't know about this we upgrade
from out party to a kegger there weren't
any Brad's at this party but loses a lot
of Emma's that sounds like fun
who's Emma a girl I like yeah i'm moving
on to the girl that I have
a thing for ya
oh wow I don't think I've heard you talk
about her before I bet this guy better
not be making anymore
how did you two meet mike tells Mike
that at that partner
hell yeah at some party I think I don't
really remember there was so blasted
drunk so what she like she's got she's
she's kind she's just a sweetheart
oh she's just a sweetheart while Mark
sounds like things are going really well
that's just so great you have any plans
weekend
well me and Brad was supposed to go see
a show but that's not having oh we could
have been to the same old knew if I said
show but maybe i would have said i was
still going with mi proof that probably
would have been consistently I'm sorry
I'm so sorry Emily I'm so sorry how are
you okay it's just been really weird
since me and him at the same group of
friends or things are messy
no I just feel really alone you know I'm
here for you
well you know i'm here for you I know
and thank you for that I just feel
really abandoned why did you break up
you chose ask about the break-up
oh I guess I guess we just kind of grew
apart
I feel like Brad changed a lot over the
summer and things were just different
when we got back home and now i'm
starting to cry
there's no point in telling anyone day
hey don't cry
hey that thing you're doing it's stupid
and dumb and don't do that just just
commiserate I guess I am
he's lost you're amazing you're you're
an amazing person also amazing same
thing i guess thanks I'm sorry for just
sit being such a mess
I'll always be here for you it's okay
i'm always be here for you
nice to be able to talk about this I
haven't really had the chance to vent
yet I know you'd do the same for me i
want to ask you something but i'm afraid
you'll hate me after I promise me you
won't hate me i could never hate you
ever at travis's party senior year
remember how we got bored and went for
that walk who we stopped at that
playground for a bit and we just laid
there and looked at the Stars
well why didn't you kiss me I didn't
that wasn't a multiple choice option
Emily if I had done that you better
believe youre but i would have been
kissing you not your but you uh oh who
are screw things of the booty was grew
up I don't know just means that i was
obviously think about it but I was too
coward
i I didn't know you felt that way
honestly and truly I didn't know you
felt that way i don't know i don't know
you didn't tell me I didn't tell you
I've just always wondered how things
would be if you did not good considering
we're different schools
I don't know it's kinda stupid I guess
let's see you should have told me it
true you should have told me what I mean
it wouldn't matter because we're at
different schools it would've been
impossible to be together like in in
that circle not impossible but I mean or
for a start of a relationship new
you know I mean I I honestly don't wish
I had I would have kissed you but right
what would I do if she was coming at me
asking me why I didn't kiss her
it's not a very nice thing to go like
well you should've told me
baby baby baby it would have been it
probably better to say that like admit
feelings now and then and I wish I'd
kissed you i wish i had i wish i had
i'll say it I'll say it out loud
yeah I have an idea maybe I could come
visit this weekend little I could really
use some time away from the school how
far away we always said we would visit
each other
what do you think as long as it's just
as friends
uh where's where's good old know there's
Brad mistakes and regrets i walked as ab
day three on the ball of art of broken
dreams truck drummer wanted
ok sure please please come visit
please come visit i would love to see
you considering i have no idea who the
hell am IA is but we'll see where things
go
what about your plans with some Emma I
can ditch her
that sounds really mean i'll make up
some excuse as lying I'll talk to her
about it
well I don't know if that's the right
thing I don't know how you're gonna talk
to her about it if you're like I don't
know what you mean by when you say
you'll talk to her about it you are you
gonna go to em and be like hey I like
this girl Emily and we can be a thing
sorry that's what it was that's all it
would take
that's all it would take fernanda hope
to begin don't I'm gonna trust you on
this one I'm trusting you that that's
what you mean when you say all talk to
her about it i'm i'm assuming that
that's the adult choice and it means
what I think it means
although i could see how it would go
another way but I don't think making up
an excuse for ditching her would be a
good idea
so I'm gonna love it
I'll talk to her about it
ok i just don't want to mess things up
well good what do you want to do this
weekend there's the buyers knowledge got
some stuff around campus whatever around
campus
yeah deprecated sounds good to me should
i bring my alcohol but yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah i did parted order
ok i'm so excited to finally come visit
oh shit i actually have to run i'll see
you this weekend
of course of course babe bid ye chapter
it's another full year later oh ok i did
like v for vendetta a lot but there's a
groom goofy goofy goofy
hi everybody hey yo yo what all I know
it's been a while since we last talked
why is that the thing that that is death
cab for cutie
I don't want your help way down the
bottom love is watching someone dies
who's gonna watch you die woo said see
that's ok I've just been going through a
lot lately everything ok yeah everything
is fine
well that doesn't sound like
everything's fine so listen I was hoping
we could talk about things of course
what's up
would you choose not to talk with him
I don't know what the choices are if you
don't I just feel like things are weird
between us
have you felt that too i don't think so
but then again I've been gone in
hibernation for like a full year i don't
think so i think it's because of last
year things have been weird since i came
to visit mark please be honest with me
did you plan that we would hook up
what how can I have a plan that what I
did
what do you plan you can what I thought
it was possible
that's judge to watch in retrospect it
all just seems so planned out
I mean we hung out with your friends
around campus then we go back to your
dorm to drink
did you want to still get really drunk
I just want it have you wanted to hook
oh I don't know is getting his message
messy territory
I know me too i just i don't know
did I do something wrong you chose ask
about yourself oh that's not what I
that's not what I thought that was Todd
she's just a lot happened really quickly
it just made me feel differently in a
bad way
no not bad just different i don't know
will we ever breathe uh oh god no kind
of questions are these two ask we still
friends
we still friends yeah at least I think
so
I'm sorry things are just really weird
for me right now but thank you for
talking to me about it we can talk
anytime any old time exactly a year from
now is good college is flying by that
doesn't sound good at all so how's your
friend Mike who's Mike we're excited
Mike entrepreneur club the innovation
center on all I want to hear is a
message be my dream
Oh
he's not really my friend anymore
yeah it sucks when people change would
soon put me about your other friend Emma
haven't seen her in a while after you
know I it's better she just a friend or
she's just a friend okay
it's weird because I'm making up reality
as we're going along so I don't think I
can do this right now
what do you mean talking right now it's
just kind of hard I've got to go soon
anyways we'll talk again later
of course of course in another year one
more year senior year of college
partay oh boy all three hundred i wasn't
a 300 stick
yeah that's probably me Emily howdy
howdy howdy howdy howdy how do you know
hey hey shake group
it's good how are you let me check your
profile our doggie when you want
something sensible my tongue is mrs.
digging my grave walk from the start
time for the last time two passages that
things could be better
it's okay sorry to hear that how have
you been
everything's been really good oh
everything girly good what's new in your
life not a lot really just finishing up
College oh I don't know if you knew me
and Brad got together even after that
awful breakup
well it was so awful because we cared
for each other so much
how's your friend am doing well
well she started dating Mike so now I
barely see here
oh I I have other friends
it's okay i have other friends 11 other
friend while college is almost over
anyway
can you believe we're almost adults I
can't judging by this conversation we've
had over the few years
nope it's definitely doesn't feel like
it's been four years high school was
soon do
yeah it was I'd rather not think about
the past though
well okay I'm just tired of reliving
memories so all set for graduation I
think so i still have to order my gown
and stuff
what are you doing the summer just hang
out here with Brad and try to find a job
and we know we can't no don't talk about
things
no we shouldn't talk about things mm she
doesn't want to talk about things
let's talk about things nope nope back
haha haha haha ok not really i just been
working and I see you this summer is
gonna be a cowardly up there we are you
doing homework berber berber you have
yourself stuff before you ever miss
things our class
oh boy oh the smallest of small times
are good same old same old demons me if
it is noted
d is listening to old stuff will we ever
be little pickle
oh boy oh boy oh boy is this it for us
or house
how's the weather wow ok gotta go okay i
think i'm going to go combined ok ok by
who
oh that's the end
oh god oh damn it Barry shit
oh boy that is that is who that is a
thing that was cool that was really cool
and interesting experience because my
problem now what's the game but with the
dialogue in there was that it didn't say
what he meant if he'd have said when I
told him to said actually you know I
take that back i don't know if there's
any way that you could have gone and
made that work out okay
I mean you probably could add a better
outcome where you would have been better
friends towards the end of that accept
and not quite such dissonant partners or
partners distant people you know it is
very interesting because it was it was
one of those things where the effort was
made and it went well but all the
options happened behind the scenes you
know to say and those could have changed
the outcome and yet
yeah I wonder like maybe if I told her
not to bring booze if things would've
been okay
or maybe if I did that it would have
been a different way anyway so I don't
really know but I could play through
this again but I don't feel like playing
through the entire game again for that
so we shall see what happens when what
happens i might look up to see if there
are now you know I look it up now
ok alright i looked it up
I'm not sure how serious is but just
from one I didn't want to spoil too much
just in case there were but from what
they were talking about people tried
over and over and over again and they
you know they they couldn't get any
different anymore from what they did and
I think that's exactly what i was
talking about the situation that it is
is kind of very difficult for people to
experience I wonder if the developer
this game experiences for themselves
because really interesting that the way
things play out things can happen but in
the end the distance and you can't
control what someone does on their own
with the other people in their lives you
know all that wrapping together makes a
really interesting dynamic and the but
the inevitability of it is really cool
I don't know if there's no other endings
but from what I saw it doesn't seem like
they're very many other endings and it
was kinda like perfect that emily is
away is the name of the game and then at
the end of it
market mover six is away so either way
that is great
I'm sorry it took me so long to play
this game but that was really cool so
let me know what you thought down the
comments below let me know if I've
assumed anything wrong in the comments
below as well and thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video